[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club the players before
you are eight of the most promising
juniors in st. Louis Missouri
today on li chess org they answer the
challenge of the city chess school in a
friendly match near the coastline of the
Black Sea is Aditi in the nation of
Georgia plays home to this Aditi chess
school today the opponents of the st.
Louis chess club today in chess has live
coverage of Zug DD vs. st. Louis
starting now
and hello chess fans Bensimon here along
with international arbiter the most
entertaining man in chest might come her
Forza DD vs. st. Louis what an
interesting match Mike tell me a little
bit about this match sure so a zig ditty
contacted our executive director tony
rich and said let's have a match and
then tony said I get my best man on the
job and here we are we assembled eight
of them are promising young scholastic
players to take on the team from Georgia
so it's going to be a lot of fun and we
this is going to be 8 on 8 and it's just
one round of games we we thank you for
staying with us over the course of this
past hour we've been trying to hook up
with our friends in Georgia on Leach s
org which is where you can see these
games they're going live right now we
want to tell you that the format of the
names game is st. Louis the letter N and
then the board number so st. Louis and
one through eight except for Henry Aaron
Lin who is Aaron's son boy but we'll
tell su n yes you su n right
so let's take a look at this tournament
format we said it when it's a friendly
unrated 8 on 8 exhibition
only one round the games will be 25
minutes per clock with a 10-second
increment and remember since this is
online you can do that pre move Mike oh
yeah but very risky
especially toward the end of the game
because they'll try to razzle-dazzle you
and a trick yes oh you've got to be
careful with that pre move alright and
of course the first team to four and a
half points will be the winner of course
all the games will go to their
conclusion but let's take a look at the
players for both teams here we've got
alternating colors and here we'll see
boards one through four and Mike take it
away for just a moment and tell us who
is playing today so okay so iris ow is
our team captain she's playing board one
she is playing against Sun tea and then
on board two we have Ashish panda
playing against Georgie Ashish will have
the black pieces
Erinn Lynn Ahrens son boy as you call
them will be playing the white pieces
against Alika and then alexander our
danny Machuca is a promising student who
just won the march knights actually with
thought three and a half points he'll
have the black pieces against Caterine
and then on board five we have Aiden
home playing against Michiel then
Selina's ow
Irish house sister will have the black
pieces against Nika on board seven
Neumann Chen will have the white pieces
against Nia and then rounding out the
team as a shishas a younger brother Adi
panda playing against Meggie Adi will
have the black pieces so we have the
white pieces on the odd boards boards
one three five and seven and we'll have
the black pieces on board two four six
and eight and hold those up there for
just a moment because I want to raise a
point here Mike we as far as feed a
ratings go these players are very very
similar in strength and a granted they
may actually be but using the Chess Club
and mark Glickman and Maxime Rashard
system the universal rating system you
can see that there is actually quite the
disparity in some situations I mean
look at board number five Aiden and
Mikkel five hundred point difference
there and and we've got to say that the
universal rating system will account for
classical rapid and blitz games it's one
rating across all systems so this these
are rapid games here came in twenty five
this raises the question is st. Louis
outmatched like we'll see we'll see how
the universal rating system because
Mikhail's need a rating is just thirteen
ninety but as you see on the screen
his urs rating is 1862 so it'll be a big
challenge for Aiden it's a case study
there's a universal rating system hold
up my goodness that is a big big
difference so we've seen the players and
we know what is up all of the games are
underway and we thank you for watching
with us on YouTube and remember to check
out the games on Lee chess but Mike
wasting no more time let's take a look
at our team captains in action all right
so we got on board number one iris
against satiny iris is playing with the
white pieces she typically for and then
you don't see this every day
Knight to c6 the nimzowitsch so this is
actually an underestimated opening I
might try to try this in my next game so
white typically plays d4 whenever you
can play d4 you know if they didn't put
any pressure on it you want to play it
right away and so black counters with d5
you know who actually plays this opening
is a grandmaster Ken West he's a big fan
of the nimzowitsch the world's only
thirteen hundred grand yeah alright urs
right yeah well ya know what is urs is
it so
ok e5 get the bishop out so you know
white just develops the night Queen to
d7 so maybe trying to castle long here
protects the pawn h6
so I guess they're afraid that if they
castle the knight will happen to g5 here
okay all right challenge the bishop she
ignores it he ignores it Knight to c3
interesting ii 6 so now iris has a
chance to double the pawns and she does
all right good job is that h4 alright
preventing the pawn onslaught of g5f 4 I
like it I like it I like it
so now oh the winky g6 so iris iris is
in control of this game I like irises
chances she's kind of like calling the
shots and like you ain't going to g5
buddy yeah but where is iris gonna
castle though now is she gonna castle
long just like satiny did because they
Castle in short in this position might
be a little dangerous so so I like
irises position here keep in mind I am
NOT analyzing with the computer so these
are just the thoughts of Missouri
Scholastic champions Oh 1990 1998 so
time has progressed so alright so let's
go to the next one huh let's go to uh
let's just go down the line let's go to
a board number 2 all right
Ashish panda with black is playing
Georgie sartania of Zog diddy all right
Knight f3 and this is this is fine
d5 I like it so Ashish counters with d5
here c4 I got to mention right now is
sheesh is actually not at his computer
so that that's his brother right there
Adi who's on board 8 so I guess he
always likes the circle around so glad
to see what else is going on there's
nothing wrong about that either
you're allowed to scroll around and
tournaments check out the other games
you know just pace yourself you know
nothing wrong with that so e 6 so so
black just voluntarily trapped in as
bishop and look what white does this is
horrible if I
was who who's bored too for for Giggy I
was are Tanya I would be I would be just
lashing out at him right now cuz the
first thing he does you just help us she
shout Wow now now my bishops free you
got the deep on still you just traded an
advanced pawn for a backwards pawn it's
like I would be I would just be oh okay
but luckily I'm not a student so as she
she's just winning now all right just
play Bishop oh so in this position he
should just break the pin up with Bishop
to e7 okay just break the pin instantly
because now when he brings out Bishop f5
he's just asking white to bring his
Queen to b3 and attack the b-pawn the D
pawn all the good stuff and there does
their he does and the last thing you
want to play is b6 here you know what
the best move in this position actually
is and I don't need a computer to tell
me fish up the CA just backwards just
I'm sorry I made that move it happens to
me off okay so you got to watch out for
that whenever they moved that C pawn out
you bring that Bishop out you weaken the
b-pawn and Queen to b3 yeah all right so
Bishop takes pawn so remove the defender
so so now look what does she she has to
do double isolate his pawns so see how
this all could have just been avoided
you could have just played Bishop e7
castle if you don't have to make any
fireworks in the opening here right just
play conservative get castled
just check off the box as you know
instead bringing out his light squared
bishop and it just led to all kinds of
problems very frustrating now Mike are
you I mean I know that you helped put
this match together but are you
officially the coach like what's your
role here well of course I'm a homer
right so I'm cheering for st. Louis but
I have no affiliation for the team iris
now is obviously the team captain
yeah so we know we have a lot of like
Diddy people watching actually today oh
good good that's about 9 o'clock p.m.
over there in Georgia
yeah very late very late but they stayed
up they're all playing in a conference
room in one of their luxurious hotels so
you're all playing as a team it's a
hotel Iberia palace I believe it's
called yes yes we got the boardroom very
nice and we have the VIP boardroom in
that st. Louis chess club obviously that
we're very lucky to have yes
rates the greats have played in that
room for sure yes world champions Garry
Kasparov has played there Magnus Carlsen
unarmed so yep we got now we get there
playing play everybody but cram nickname
of a bit yeah yeah all right so so white
plays a very good movie does not want to
be checked so he plays a three very well
bishop attacks the night so he's trying
to double his pawns up so if white white
should just retreat his Knight instead
he's like I'll take I'll take some Maya
I'll take some double pawns - okay so
instead she's just like instead of
giving him double pawns he's like please
undal my pawns hey it's like no sale no
sale and now Ashish has missed out his
chance to double his pawns but maybe he
doesn't want to
maybe he's begging for white on board to
the castle so he can get some action on
the G file and maybe even push this pawn
h5h for so okay so yeah I like white in
this position but not by much okay so
let's go with our Erin Lynn he's one of
the promising stars of the st. Louis
chesco the sky is the limit for this guy
he has no ceiling he could be a future
Grandmaster playing in the board room
here Erin Lin played white pieces on
board number three against Alika Cariah
of zag diddy all right so yeah II for c5
the Sicilian I like this opening be six
d for typical stuff so okay so night of
tax the pond so we have to deal with it
okay so Knight to c3 so I would expect
Bishop b4 here excellent so here we go
again
double isolated pawns but he chooses not
to give air and double isolated funds
and plus isolating the a pond so the
kids got to really watch out for that
weakness you know castle so still still
saying I can take the isolated ponds
take take days like forget about it you
had your chance yeah ten chances to take
that of that I'm not giving you any more
chances
all right so I was expect to see three
here a3 c3 might be a little better but
it gets the job done okay so he's gonna
be on Chet Oh his uh they're both gonna
fianc at all the bishops here okay oh
look at this look at this we have a
sacrifice we have a sacrifice but is it
sound Mike is it sound at first glance
I'm going to say no but if I was air and
I would have taken this instead when she
probably did it so big check big check
big check big check and now he's gonna
threaten checkmate oh yeah oh dear is
right oh dear is right how do we stop
the checkmate how do we stop it oh we
have a funky way to stop it with why we
will fish up the e5 is there any other
way it looked the eve one oh my gosh so
the funniest way to stop this checkmate
is actually by bringing your bishop here
and then just giving back the piece yes
for you if you want to be funny I don't
know if I have sometimes play chess for
humor you know it's like laughs they're
less funny way to get out of this
situation right because f3 is just oh my
god all right every actress it doesn't
stop me g3 obviously doesn't stop me no
Erin's
either laughing or crying right now I
can't tell you must see the funny
position I think about area it's always
smiling nothing to get that he's like
nothing to break my stress so it's like
two minutes before the round was
supposed to start all the seven players
are here except for Aaron then we're
like oh god am I gonna sweat it out he
just walks I hey so they aren't played a
few more moves on yeah this is this is
not going to be pretty for Aaron no oh
oh oh my god just just call in the
clowns or whatever oh my gosh this is
just so you got a yeah Knight f4 see
your queen didn't need him anyway
oh and then he's like get out of here
Queen get out of here so big Chuck
coming up obviously and this is gonna be
all she wrote so now he's threatening
with that he's discovered the pin on the
G pawn here so he's threatening Queen
takes h3 Jack let's see if Aaron sees it
he does and now once he plays but Knight
e3 it's just like this is unfortunate
this is a reasonable probably for a
white obviously but hey he's gonna make
a go of it neither team tournament you
never want to resign anyway a place you
never want to be the first to lose
either so you might as well play it out
to the bitter end
Queen to F into G 3 what does that
actually threaten here Oh probably just
Knight takes G to Bishop takes G to etc
alright so Bishop takes e5 here this is
let's just buzz through this move
because this is going to be a check
queen takes rook because we got other
games to get to here all right well it's
just through the mercy rule on this one
and move to a bordo board for where
hopefully things are going better for
the st. Louis
Club so on board for we have a good ol
Alex Angus black Alex Angus black okay
taking on ekaterina beck vaya all right
so II for we got the French defense here
though been of our of variation here
some very good one so check I mean this
this is this this can't be real check so
obviously just helping the guy out with
c6 here night up so do we just retreat
with Bishop e7 or do we get castled
castled so so maybe he's eyeing that h7
square as well so h3 he's not as
ambitious as Aaron Lin's opponent may be
luckily for us so we get to develop a
check here that's good oh and now he
retreats the bishop off that that very
juicy diagonal there so so that's good
good for us Queen to a5 and right as as
Ben Feingold says you never want to play
Grandmaster Ben Feingold who actually is
in the other Georgia Atlanta Georgia he
always says you never want to play
Bishop d2 it just means you're
retreating you're not doing well so
black definitely has the advantages I
mean this this this is not good for a
white to set up I know it looks like
cautious and everything but that's
that's not what you want that's that
there's not your dream position as white
here so he retreats as well Castle okay
now if only the bishop and the Queen
were introverted you'd have a lot better
going on you know because that Bishop
check on h2 isn't very scary even if he
moves the knight it's not very scary a
knight up probably uh
well I don't want to speculate but
probably in that position Knight f8 was
probably more accurate because that
Knight is not going to have much of a
future on b6 sad to say sad to say oh no
oh no oh no now that was Bishop as
getting active so what do we do here I'm
votin it--to e5 let's just get it up
there and see what's happening yes good
good job Alex saying good job good job
and Alexander far star scholastic
instructor Danny masuka's one of his
star pupils and Alexander's progressed
mightily in the last couple months
absolutely you know i-i've seen you'll
notice all these players are in the same
room despite this just being an online
match and there's a lot of team unity
going on I see Alex is one of the kids
who's going up and going around and
taking a look at everyone's board now
this is I mean it's just an exhibition
but you still don't want to have any
like draw offers on the board when you
need to win but it's good it's good for
team unity wouldn't you agree yes so
when I was constructing this match
there's a Alex Angus part of the Froyo
gang him Aiden Wong Selena Zhao and Rex
true unfortunately isn't China and
cannot participate but they're all part
of the Froyo gang they uh they trained
together they come to the club together
and they're always having a grand old
time let's say they're they support each
other and there's a fun group and and
there and that helps in chess when you
have a you know support you know it just
makes it makes everything better
you know for sure yeah and even though
we had the delay you could tell that all
the kids up in the the board room were
having a really good time actually yeah
I think they maybe even turned on the
stream a little bit maybe weren't to
entertain with it but yeah yeah Newman
shines also part of the gang yeah
they're just dancing around just having
fun
there weren't reckless they weren't
restless they were just having fun
following the big Fabiano Magnus match
that's going on right now so what are
you guys doing watching this right oh
yeah yeah I guess I guess we are we are
in the midst of the Greinke tournament
yes yes unfortunately Fabiano one of our
MVPs
the protest League unfortunately had the
commitment of playing grunty instead of
playing in San Francisco live April 7th
and 8th to watch the art art to play to
participate with the Archbishop's on
board one against our foes armenia
chengdu pandas are the turtles i don't
know how to pronounce wherever the
turtles are from Moby Jia and maybe can
help me out and I don't know I don't
know you don't know I'll have to figure
that one we will talk about the
protesting a little bit later on are we
caught up to date with Alex Aang's game
but we are not he just slammed down
Knight e4
okay so here we are here we go sir here
we are so uh so white takes it takes
back so now the night is under attack
night retreats attacks the pun okay
making some well looked you know so his
King now has a flight square doesn't
wanna get back grope checkmated that's
always nice Bishop back and now the very
ambitious a5 a5 of all the players so
far I have been most impressed with
Alex's game for sure Knight fork so net
captures so this is yeah the only plan I
did not agree with Alex was putting the
knight 2p6
but with Knight to c4 he's kind of
helping them out and and Alex is like
check I don't care that's fine it's fine
I don't care
you know I'm just gonna get out of Chuck
it's fine oh all right but this is no
problem either there's no problem either
so Queen attacks the rook threatening uh
lots of stuff so just move up the bishop
just move up the bishop part part
perfect so now the rooks are connected
he's got all the pieces out he is firmly
in the middle game and doing great this
train actually helps Alex because look I
mean this white's bishop is obviously
better than blacks and white takes it so
that trade is great ok so you lose a
punt
you know big one big one look what we
got that open F file now we got this
Queen Bishop battery
I still like Alex's chances
alright connect the Rose Queen retreat
alright Queen to the F file here we go
Queen retreats again alright
rook to g6 this is getting good this is
getting good
so yeah if you ever get down in chess
like a pawn actually I think that was
more of a pawn sacrifice anyway but
don't let it deter you looked on the
bright side like okay so I'm down upon
but okay but I got the F file now
and your king is on the G file so let's
get a rook on the G file so now this
pawn is in a pen and we got we got
things going for us okay so okay so
white pine thinks he's better he's up a
pond but black is on the attack
let's just see just see how it goes so
let's let's keep an eye on that game for
sure and look and also when you're on
the attack usually you're gonna have a
time advantage so he's got a nice time
advantage on the kid from Cydia all
right so let's uh let's try a board
number 5 what 5 yeah I gotta tell you
Mike we have some unfortunate news but
news we expected Howard number 3 our
superstar player Aaron lien has gone
down it checkmate on the board against
Alito right way to mate play to mate try
four tricks
yeah that's the Scholastic rule the
Great Scott all right so we have a huge
time advantage on board 5 so we have
Aiden long against Mikheil he'll see
janaba
let's just press this button all right
so that makes it easy so Aiden has the
white pieces so II four we got another
Sicilian c3 either called the c3
Sicilian on the ala pin well usually
play that I move to but alright that's
just semantics so Knight attacks the
pawn push the pawn attack the knight d4
the trade of pawns bishop attacks the
Queen so we've seen this before we've
seen this before
every time you move out that Bishop your
be pawn is gonna be exposed so I can bet
all my money on what this moves gonna be
Queen to b6 attacking the pawn ok but
that's good that's good that's good dis
good the last thing you wanted to play
here was b3 so alex is very very
interested in what his teammates doing
check it out check it out okay now Mike
just to clarify are these players
allowed to talk to each other in any way
no no the only thing we did not go over
this but the only thing they can do and
I should have really gone over this is
they are allowed to ask the team captain
like should I draw but but iris would
not be able to look at the board
yes so no and no advice based on the
position just on the score situation I
see yes so this is red alert for a white
here his queen is pinned to his king but
there's an easy solution Knight to c3
oh he's piling on he's piling on do we
want the play rook the c1 here we have
to okay
h6 all right bishop retreats Knight
takes pawn takes Bishop attacks the rook
no problem no problem
rooks on the open B file b6 so now the
bishop can either get beyond shadowed
along the long diagonal or ask for the
trade on a6 I would think he's more like
I ain't b7 Wow Wow Wow
all right so we're context the Queen
Queen moves out of danger rip back to b3
attacking the bishop
so he's like okay so okay so here's the
moment of truth for for white here he
could try the night sack but that looks
kind of dubious or he can just retreat
the g3 and then push h4 so he takes the
more conservative route that's what I
would have played Knight back to e7
eyeing this nice square on f5 or d5
probably doesn't know where to go
Bishop attacks the Queen here so Queen
to a5 is the only way so he really wants
to trap that Queen but it doesn't look
like that's going to be a possibility c4
so he's just like let's trade the
Queen's
interesting oh so Wow so black made an
oppressive move here because if he would
just trade the Queen's Queen takes King
takes that bishop is trapped can't
retreat the d6 can't retreat the c5
can't retreat to B for B 2 and C 1 will
be covered so excellent move by black in
this position who is this meek this is a
McHale right yes it should have a good
good good move very very good
so castle attacks the bishop so bishop a
text so take take so so black conceded a
lot but he saved the piece you'd rather
have double isolated pawns than dropping
a bishop obviously and now he's got
double pawns over here but he can use
that G file possibly to his advantage so
let's look at this position one more
time here in this position I would
actually probably recommend more King
the e2 because the Queen's are up the
board you're kind of already in end game
instead of castling but we'll see how
yep yep do some pawn hunting good good
good good good
so now okay see this is dangerous now
with that King on G 1 instead of e 2
that would have been a perfect spot
because if Bishop takes Knight King
takes and you're all set so if he
retreats this Knight here you're gonna
see some action on the G file and Mike I
gotta point out look at the difference
in the time on the clocks right here we
have alexand who's up by i mean 17
minutes give or take this I believe this
is uh pardon me Aiden Wang Wang but so
but but black was kind of in some
trouble there whereas Bishop and Queen
we're getting harassed so he had to play
that very precise or else as you saw in
the air in Lin game your game can go you
can fall fast unfortunately so
but now he's he's got the momentum now
so he should be able to play a little
bit quicker here so as we were
anticipating route to g8 f3 is a good
here and oh the Knights coming in nice
coming into e3 here rip to d8 huh so
preparing a d5 possibly ok so now he's
got his knight in the e3 so you see
another target on this g2 square so rook
F - no need to sacrifice the exchange
their knight harasses the rook real
harass is the knight and there it is he
got the shot the one thing you did want
to happen happened I hate it when that
happens it's like he has one threat in
the position and you didn't nullify it
this could have all been avoided if he
wouldn't have castled he should have
understood that he was in an end game
played his king up the e2 it would have
got the same job done and a lot of this
could have just been prevented so now
take the pawn now Knight e3 is coming in
so he's got three men on the pawn now
but we got two defenders and the King is
obviously the worst offender because
Kings cannot capture defended pieces
obviously and now we see that the black
player from Ziggy has drifted under a
minute out of red alert I gotta tell ya
that's not the only case of time trouble
severe time trouble in on board number
six
irises sister selena has black and she
has the good end of the time against
Nica
Cavalia Anika from Diddy has 38 seconds
left
alright so what is going on in this
position one two three four five one two
three four five so they each have the
same number of pawns they each have the
same color Bishop but
the white player from sir diddy Anika
has the rook instead of the night but
that night that nights pretty awesome on
e5 can't be can't be forced away by a
pawn
nice outpost gives them a give Selena a
big check here so King up it does defend
the F pawn but it stays on this critical
dark squared diagonal so Queen back
protects the pawn here so what is iris
gonna do I so iris can fork here but I
don't know if that was the best route so
okay so yeah they had to trade the
Queen's the Knight takes pawn all right
so rook forked the two pawns oh boy oh
boy
King f6 here is the best move in my
opinion he six wow that pawn is gonna be
tough to stop Bensimon that b-pawn is
gonna be tough to stop you know it's a
passed pawn with a clear path and and
and with that 10 second increment and
this is this this is gonna be this is
gonna be lights out for Selena
unfortunately unless you can pull
something out of the Hat so Knight takes
you got to get that Bishop on this
diagonal to cover b8 okay so Bishop 2f
Bishop the f4 should be the the plan
here well you think Selena is thinking
about just taking the pawn straight away
with the knight is she that best friend
she's not this for yet okay we'll have
time especially if we get on that good
good Selena
so it's Selena knows knows that knows
the threat and you know yeah you don't
want to give up here because you know
you have you know your own past pawn but
unfortunately that King is covering the
e-file pretty well and now you just put
your bishop in front of it this this
game and let's just go to the next one
okay we'll put a fake
winning for uh buddy Frank went in for
it winter is official all right let's go
to the Newman game huh board number
seven newman shen louis oh so it gives
the thumbs-up like you see something we
don't maybe see you think she's playing
with the stop cuz yet Newman Newman
knows thirteen seconds not even at the
board not even at the board when is it
when is when the sky isn't so much time
trouble here
so yeah King King there looked like a
good move here so let's see what's going
on in here we got bishops of the same
color
endgame one two three four five one two
three four five so we got five pawns for
the black pieces we are white in this
position numinous white one two three
four five they both have five two five
puns this is just gonna be a draw we can
just we can just go to the next one this
is draw I don't care if this guy's got
fifteen seconds left he can pre move
Bishop Bishop Bishop Bishop Bishop
Bishop Bishop it's just bishop shuffling
bishop shuffling yep so this one is uh
yeah Bishop h7 Bishop g6 blah blah blah
I know these are kids now Mike yeah well
this this is interesting as so so yeah
yeah I take it all back white could have
an idea to run black out of moves so
so let's see so Bishop to c8 looks good
Mike I think you're more nervous than
the kid yeah so so you what you wanted
to play Bishop to c8 here
Oh six seconds six five four three and
these times are 100% accurate this isn't
like the dgt clock so maybe it's a
second off right oh this is it yeah so
Newman Newman Newman's forcing it
so now Bishop the c8 here King to d2 so
he's just repeating new Newman's get no
reason to really ever get off of this
III square so now he's gonna put Newman
to the test because you see there's no
way for black to break in because of the
C pawn but there is a way for white to
break in on d4 so I expect a five here
and now King back to E oh yeah nice nice
so let's just try to run black out of
moves here King to e3
unfortunately a breaking news here Adie
panda our board 8 player has been
checkmated against Meggie Sobecki AA a.d
we never knew you get to see it but
maybe maybe that was for the best but it
looks like he put up a heck of a fight
though you see you at the bitter end
he's trying to checkmate white as well
so mean so noble effort by ID you know
we'll probably see all these games go to
a checkmate if they're decisive and no
resignations wouldn't you think yes that
that is the plan and the team of NCI
there's never one a resign you want to
hold on to the bitter end so so right
now is DD chess school lead st. Louis
two to nothing remember board a half
clinches the match they're very
interested in Newman's game again men
all right try to run this get a kid out
of moves
all right yes this is gonna be a very
important game here for this match we
can pull this out but I mean is there
still away maybe we can put our Bishop
oh we just lost the pun but he lost the
pun exciting here and with the guy who
time pressure he's got to play pretty
precise so let's hunt down this H pawn
there's there even time to look is that
King and the as they say the boxer
whatever so if he plays a for King D to
a3 King C - a - I think we're in the Box
I think we're in the Box gotta go he's
gotta go okay very exciting so we right
now we have a passed pawn he's got a
passed pawn it's alright get get King be
too obvious instant instant instant
instant instant I know what's the
thinker about what's the what's the
thinker about - he was in the box but
then he what happened a fell out of the
box no it's good to be in the box but
once you're in the Box you got it you
still got a play when you're in the box
okay you can't just sit there with sand
in your face okay you got to go and you
know these these games we knew they'd be
wild these are kids playing it doesn't
matter if they have high
ratings are not it's it's unpredictable
you know you got a feel for it you got a
feel for Newman here but he's gonna play
on I think it's over you know I think
it's over oh my god so this could be
three oh and then we had the fake win
with the Selena game let's see if
there's let's see if there's any news on
that front is this on the board six
board six is over white is victorious
that means that Salinas Oh
has fallen to Nika Cabal yeah Mike I got
to tell you a three-zip for this is a
giddy chess school I know that they are
probably cheering right now you know
because you're right
so they almost they can clinch the
Clinton at least a tie with the match
but we were kind of top heavy let's
let's just say we were top-heavy right
so let's say get some good news on us
IRA's our shish Panda
we obviously didn't get any good news on
the air in Linn game let's go to like
let's just stop let's just go back to
the team captains and see what's going
right iris out playing white against
Sonny marks Shaba right so the Queen
under is under attack it claims that
somebody is plus one one two three four
five six pawns for white seven for black
but iris might be reclaiming that pawn
on the h-file pretty soon I would expect
Wow
oh wow a lot of lot of pressure on this
e pawn here Mike comer on board 5/18
long it has defeated McHale City Nava
scoring st. Louis in a checkmate in the
center of the board look at that you've
got to love it yeah we just had a we
have a host of Friday quantified it's
called a name of a youtube show and
Aiden just had he put Brandon Stanfield
in a in a cool checkmate in the middle
of the board that was kind of similar
like that of course like Queen checkmate
that was aided by a knight so if you
want to check out our studio short
quantified its episode number three with
aidan with a cool checkmate he's the
second interview when that one so you
saw time code on that time code oh god
its way back that's a that's a long
episode of quantified the old man chest
so go to like 10 to 12 minutes Mike we
got it we got these games are breaking
down that's a bad thing about only
having one round they all start at the
same time it's all coming to a head
right now yeah so what do you have we
got we got we got board to the Ashish
panda game a she's just playing with the
black pieces
it looks like it's dead even they both
have past epon so that's something you
don't see every day right where you have
you know each site has a past pun on the
other side on the same file just look
unusually very unusual but to a shishas
credit he also has a past deep on but
white has a past F pawn as well so white
has a head right has a nice blockade
though but you do you really want a rook
just to be a blockade or proof this is a
looking pretty dryish here who is gonna
break through first I don't know who can
where did that rook even come from okay
so he wanted the work to be the defender
of the Jeep on so stop any shenanigans
yeah this one's this is gonna be tough
for either player to really make any
progress on board for we have the
matches only draw thus far as
Ekaterinburg theäôve is a diddy with the
white pieces has drawn and alex zhang
with black alexengel one of st. Louis's
players that brings the score total to
three and a half one and a half is up
dee dee leads yeah so it looks like
black had some pressure white had to
force a draw right but but in a team
event when you're winning like Zook
diggy unfortunately is that was a good
good plan just
worse the draw and call it a day there
it is there it is the perpetual and
there's nothing Alex could do about it
but good for Alex he got on the board
first was it well that was our second
player that got on the board and with
Ada Wong with the victory as well so one
and a half where we're starting to amass
a couple points here a couple
okay and now iris now is down in the in
the Red Alert column under 40 seconds
here and she is still just down the pawn
but there's a lot of pressure on the e
plum but but notice that iris has
maneuvered her night over to the Kings
territory here so maybe she's thinking
about just getting a checkmate here
maybe just go all out with b4 b5 and you
know a retreat the night oh my goodness
oh we have all other news here we Mike
board number 7 newman Shen has flagged
he has run out of time straight up
against zouk Diddy's Shanaya
and that will do it that clinches the
match for these in city chess school I
want to be the first to say because I
know that you're you're very hurt right
now
congratulations to the zuc diddy chess
school but we still have two more games
that are in progress but they will
clinch this match it's always nice to
win a match and congratulations to a
signatory I'm telling you the universal
rating calm man check it out one rating
system across all time controls they
were I mean in my opinion quite
underrated when it comes to their feet a
versus their urs and we could see there
in the the opening what their rating
difference would be right because Vijay
you know they they take an account just
certain tournaments that are feed a
rated man Plus you have that play feed a
rated players in that feed a event to go
towards your feet a rate so it's very
limiting kind of where the urs is all
incumbents
basic race so so yep there is some good
job whoever created yo you know
everybody's the super band of
mathematicians no but it really is a
neat rating system the thing is it
hasn't gained a lot of traction yet
simply because we don't know a lot about
it yet it's all like secret proprietary
information they haven't released it yet
like we work at the Chess Club we
haven't even seen the inner workings of
the universal rating comm check it out
but thanks for joining us here on Lee
chess org we're staying with it to the
end guys and we still have two games
left it's a top two boards
IRA's out in trouble on board number one
30 seconds left down a pawn as well and
and they got the past cheap on so passed
pawns have been a quite a credit
struggle for the st. Louis team they
just can't seem to stop them win uh when
all said and done lots of Queen
promotions but that's kind of what you
see when you play to the end you know
usually you just tip it before it comes
to that point but you know we're making
them play it out and when you play it
out you know you get some queens oh and
what a what a nice maneuver by black
your Knight takes d4 Wow so this pawn is
obviously pinned cuz uh to the Queens so
now iris is down bytes whoo and 14
seconds left that's why when the knight
was up on c5 iris probably should have
just gone for it with b4 b5 and try to
any kind of checkmate just put the
pressure on but uh this is gonna be
tough and it looks like this eeep on is
gonna fall now as well no but if they
know the Queen is well even then the
knight is protecting the F point as well
this is gonna be tough I don't see
anything wrong with rook takes III in
this position so let's see if it
actually happens all right so
the satiny is uh the board one of Zhu
Diggy is uh under the minute but with
that ten-second increment it's not all
that bad so so okay black just retreats
he's like I'm a no-pressure to take the
e pawn here all right so so the knight
the Knights acting pretty nice holding
down the fort here but oh gosh here
comes Knight to e5 not if I was playing
I would stomp this move as hard as I
could so everybody in the tournament all
could hear it oh my god my color must
have played a great move and sometimes
those great moves aren't aren't like oh
I won your queen or something sometimes
it's just I got my night on the coolest
outpost you'd ever seen and screw it in
right yeah maybe maybe say something to
your opponent like I ain't ever move and
I ain't ever move there's nothing you
can do about it do they have a chat
window so they can train yes yes yes yes
yes so yeah first thing Aaron did even
though it was late to the game was yeah
chat with the opponent Newman was
chatting is like oh you know you know hi
I'm from st. Louis yeah that's why we
have a st. Louis for cystic it's like oh
I doubt they can even speak English but
but I don't know I don't know what uh
what language they have I don't think
it's one of the major languages there
but I think I mean there are people who
speak English and of course we you'd see
in the chat Levon bargatze one of those
players who former st. Louis Archbishop
yes him in priyadarshan can a pan where
there are two IMS in in one of our first
inaugural season so always a nice good
fan of LeBron forgot see yeah I wonder
what he's up there he wasn't Baltimore
for a while I wonder if he's still still
there but we digress read across okay so
this is now let's go to the UH well well
we got a fork on the board we got a fork
on the board so so yeah III really don't
understand
well one he he moved the night off of
that awesome square and plus he didn't
the e pond when he had had the chance so
sunny is not plain like precise but give
him some some credit here he is under a
minute here
you know also playing our team captain
who was also very well so so iris has
really mounted a comeback just by
hanging in there you know and just just
make it moves and just just just playing
so okay so okay so Knight to f3 even
though the night is now on the sixth
rank you think okay I'm in a deeper
territory but Knights are almost better
on the fifth rank than the six rank or a
big check on the board
big Chuck so iris has to trade Queens
now she has no choice she must trade
Queens and play rook to e2 so let's just
do it cuz that's what you've got to do
it doesn't look good after she trades
look at this tactics - I know about
rookie - what do I know what do I know
about anything here I was making me look
like a fool but I'm glad for her yeah
yep so uh it's called removing the
defender so obviously if he plays King
to d7 you know protecting the Queen it's
gonna be even worse cuz rook to d8 will
be on the way good job iris I mean to be
fair though after rook d8 can't satiny
just move the King back to see oh he
takes okay yeah takes takes but now well
yeah it's looking good looking good for
iris now to comeback that comeback is on
but it's not over yet
satiny still has this pawn as we know is
a is a detriment but but yeah iris is
like I'm gonna checkmate you Rick h7
Queen there and it's gonna be light out
so king c1 they moved the knight to c5
attacking the Queen iris gotta be that's
why you don't pre move in these things
you don't want to slam work h7 here so
uh Queen back okay oh now we'll satiny
finally take the e pod that's it that's
the story of the match Knight takes III
is looking good so now
we takes a five check but I mean I've
been wrong before I've been wrong before
but yet check good King up Brooke h7
check yes King to b6 let's see how IRS
is gonna kind of wrap this one up where
are you gonna go IRS this is still as
pretty as it looks for iris it's there's
still work to be done still work to be
done
threatening the discovered Chuck King
and Queen Iran the same diagonal or so
get it off there all right but now we
got Queen to e2 check always check
always check always check yep good
so King King back to b6 and then how are
we gonna get our Queen to check on b4
here
did we just play Queen to e1 Queen to d2
say it same principle but this is a
little bit better because now she has
the option to clean the d4 check so
really keeping her options open
very good a5 Queen the d4 check as
expected and oh this is gonna okay King
to a6 how can we wrap this one up we
just go inch by inch by inch maybe we'll
just play Queen to c5 here and Mike
breaking news this is the last game
going because on board to draw Ashish
panda has been checkmated st. Louis's
own black player Ashish panda has been
checkmated against Georgie sartania
so that brings their lead right now to
five and a half to one and a half and
look and look yeah like I was saying
this is never easy with the Jeep on but
interesting too
so after g2 where did we do this Oh
after g2 I got it I got it cut rook to
g5 and then that'll wrap it up alright
so well check good check yeah if I if
I'm if I'm
iris I played Queen 2f1 here right and
then after g2 just our Queen to G to
here just this let's just stop that
Queen to g1 okay same principle again
get our rook to the H file our F file
and then rook to f3 hunt the pawn down
and call it a day
iris is not in time pressure anymore has
+8 now about ready to be +9 don't yet
don't do anything fancy just eliminate
the threat
Chuck blocks the check give her another
check just just start yeah just just get
as many checks in as possible Queen to
f1 just check them the death and that
might be it no he can block with a d3
here and black resigned white is
victorious and we got another point we
got another point huh that's the top
board top board
yeah that's account for if it was
weighted right eight points the go sheet
better so our team captain takes down
the team captain from significant back
actually down in exchange but it didn't
deter she kept fighting and uh got the W
absolutely and so we have to give a
shout out to Iris and Aiden long the two
players who won for the the st. Louis
team today a hard-fought matchup is very
very tough I figured it would be as I'm
sure you did well for sure so I think we
should talk to our team captain and who
knows maybe even Aiden both both good
interviews yeah both smart articulate
children yep yeah so while we are
waiting for this far to talk with our
players you mentioned the pro chesa
earlier and I want you to tell because
April the weekend of April 7th big Final
Four event tell us about it oh yeah
great so it's actually gonna be live on
stage at the Folsom arena basically as a
1500 square root of 1500 so yeah see
capacity thank you very much it's much
bigger than 1,500 square feet it's like
a converted warehouse in the heart of
San Francisco and there's a bar area
like the League of Legends and like it's
like an eSport atmosphere now yeah and
that's different because the the protest
League has always been exclusively
online and we're talking about a
worldwide
audience of people worldwide teams from
China everywhere in the US right a
Canada it goes really everywhere in the
world but this is the first time that
the players will meet in one city for
the eSports finale yes the st. Louis
Archbishop's obviously have a big
home-field advantage because our flight
to San Francisco will only be about four
and a half to five hours well the people
from Chengdu somewhere in Eastern Europe
the Turtles and Armenia why they have to
fly all the way across the pond and get
to us and a jetlag is going to be an
issue and most of our players are
actually getting there on Thursday and
we won't have to plan till Saturday so
we get a time to rest up see the beach
eat some great food in San Francisco and
really just relax and get mentally
prepared for the match the protest
league is hosted on chess comm that's
their broadcast partner you can watch
the games there and also for more
information protests League comm if
you're not not gonna make the trip out
to San Francisco but it will be a fun
time yeah so it'll be Saturday 10:00
a.m. Pacific time will be the live
drawing of the lots and then the first
match will start right at 10:15 on
Saturday April 7th 10:15 Pacific time
all right so about noon here in st.
Louis wonderful okay and you know the
Archbishop's they've been champions
before going back to when this thing was
just the US chess League and so yeah
let's see if we can do it again
defending champs yeah wait we got we got
a lot to prove right so we're gonna have
one of our st. Louis players come in and
talk to us in just a moment but let's
take a break first and we'll be back for
more today in chess as the st. Louis
Chess Club celebrates its 10th
anniversary the US Championships return
to st. Louis for the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and Sabina
Pfizer will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
ten years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club
or there's a weekend vacation on one
tank trip in a nearby city you won't
wanna skip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with chess 24 Premium Membership I'm
Mike Matheny whether you play chess for
fun or want to boost your child's
academic performance come visit the
Chess Club and scholastic Center of st.
Louis right here in the chess capital of
the u.s. from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over 100 schools our
Center across from the World Chess Hall
of Fame the Central West End has it all
so whether you've played for years or
never before we invite you to experience
all chess has to offer
well happy early april fools everybody
it turns out we are with the champions
of the match
iris now with that victory actually gave
the Saint Luis jr. bishops or whatever
you want to call them the championship
huh cuz it turned that Adi panda
actually played with the white pieces on
board eight when he was supposed to play
with black so whenever you you see your
pairing you can just sit down as the
white pieces and just make them say hey
I thought I was supposed to be white so
that's what I did trick them
it worked so I defined it victorious I
resolved victorious st. Louis victorious
and good news for us huh yeah yeah
whatever
alright so you want to go over your game
and see I see your big comeback at the
end huh yeah okay great so so you were
supposed to have white and you had the
white and okay we were at UH so okay so
here we go efore 96 you don't see this
very often yeah um I don't know if he
like I probably he just plays this cuz
he seemed like he knew what he was doing
yeah I don't know I can play like Knight
f3 and he can play e5 and get transpose
but yeah whenever I play this or play
against us I strive for them never to be
able to play d5 yeah that's a good point
because after d4 d5 it's kind of hard to
decide what to do with the e pawn but
also at the same time c4 maybe Knight c3
is best yeah but then after a 5 he gets
like a good version of it
double King pawn ok oh it's a shameless
plug
if you watched my beginner breakdown
videos it was uh it's called a simple
move by a simple man I forced the guy I
move tend to actually play d6 instead of
the d5 so if you want to checked out
that video after the broadcast
feel free to check
one out okay so d4 so he gets d5 and
right away you advance Bishop f5 so so
this is this is actually kind of crucial
here so he's I NC - yeah but I just
thought this is like you know a French
or a caro-kann position where black has
a knight on c6 and he can't play c5 so
right so it's actually kind of blocking
them so if he played night to see Knight
to be four I guess we're just gonna play
yeah night a3 and then I play c3 next
move and I kicked the knight back I'm
not even sure like the knight might be
fine once it goes to c2
I got you okay so Queen to d7 so now you
knew he was going to Castle long yeah so
then I thought but if he wants to castle
long and then and I like and I Castle
short he probably knows what he's doing
and also I'm not quite sure that my
attack is actually that fast so so you
just bring out your Bishop to protect
the pawn I was also considering Bishop
d3 yeah yeah but yeah whatever you want
yeah h6 so I guess he was I guess he was
eyeing right after oh yeah so he's
playing g5 here yep so Bishop so he does
Castle long after Knight c3 I'm not sure
about that but on the other hand I don't
know what else to do right just get your
pieces on see what develops here Bishop
takes yeah yeah and so yeah so he gave
you the option to double Pollan's and
you took it and then yeah I was very
impressed with this move yeah h4 I
thought h4 was really strong because no
after I took before I took actually I
didn't think it and then after I took I
was like oh no he's gonna play g5
everywhere I have to stop that yeah yeah
he's there good good you saw his plan
and yes you prevented it that excellent
and then g6 no no I I honestly thought
g6 was just bad I expected like f6
yeah so so after 92 he does play the
move f6 much to a grandmaster Ben fungal
chagrin ya know and here I thought for a
while I was considering maybe I should
have played Knight f4 instead and I was
looking at lines so like can you make
movies I cannot make moves unfortunately
on I was pretend okay so like Knight f4
and then F takes e5 and I was looking at
night takes g6 rook on h8 is hanging but
then he can play something like e for
Knight takes h8 he takes f3 and I have
no idea what's going on because if I
take the pawn he's gonna play Queen age
7 and my Knights trapped and if I don't
take the pawn and then he's gonna take
on g2 and he has a bunch of pawns in
activity so I wasn't sure about that and
I was just like and after night afore he
can like even play Queen f7 and probably
e6 just bad so like maybe it's just
better to play simple engine yeah so you
avoid the complications with the take it
gets his Knight out
and now Knight and rook e8 is like the
obvious move now actually I have some
issues because he's gonna play g5 and
once he plays g5 I think he's just
better and there's no way we can prevent
it huh why I went Knight c3 but now I
just I wasted so many moves
I haven't casted yet mm-hm and he's
gonna get G five minute if he wants and
I'm assuming you want a Castle queenside
yeah okay because that's once I played
h4 I pretty much was set along great
yep Knight so now Queen to d2 huh yep
good yeah I I think I'm just worse here
I'm not really sure what went wrong but
now now this is definitely much worse
because III is gonna be weak
forever-ever-ever forever-ever-ever yeah
yeah later in the game he pounds down
Knight to e4 but then he then he moves
it again so we'll get to that position
later but but yeah that was interesting
that he finally got there and then as
soon as he got there he moved it but
already shipped d6 was strong right
because
now no 95 and well I can do it probably
maybe this was my best shot because what
I had in the game was just dead loss
like Knight d5 Knight takes e5 Knight
takes e5 Bishop chase so you so you
retreat Knight f2 here and so now he's
just gonna pile up on e3 another thing
about that well we'll get to that
position too is in a game he could have
taken on e3 at one oh yeah and he didn't
he played Knight d5 and I was so
confused
yeah right we'll get we'll get to that
that position shortly here so rook
protects the pawn yeah I think probably
maybe that one was the wrong rook
because well oh yeah because although
you have this this H point is protected
well no because I think later I wanted
my rook on d1 because d4 was protected
and I might have four shots but I don't
even know this is really bad already
well if you played this one if you
played the that one then you wouldn't be
able to play rook to g1 that no no I I
wanted to play g4 but I could never get
it to work and now he he has bishop g3
and i can't really do anything about it
so you just protect it just our queen up
i just kind of making picking get a
little bit safer that way there's no
possible pain on them you know because
once he plays f4 then i can't take in
that position yeah so now a3 was just uh
it's your turn because I know I thought
um I thought there was slight chance he
might take on a chore but it taking h4
is probably bad that's just my opinion
guys right now I can't move at all once
you take I'm down a pawn but at least I
can sort of move I think I think in the
live broadcast which is obviously it's
still the live broadcast but when the
game was live this is the point that we
started watching again after the opening
so okay so this is kind of what we saw
earlier in the match
so Queen here and I thought you were in
a lot of trouble here yeah I'm in some
but not as I don't think it's as bad as
it was before the only issue is I have
like
I don't know two minutes and he s like
hey yeah you're you're almost in the
critical zone so so rook takes Queen
takes rook back Queen back Ellen so rook
attacks the Queen Queen attacks the
pollen knight to d3 here yeah that's
what I was thinking that you might play
like Knight to c5 and now I was thinking
you were just play like b4 b5 and see
what was up but you never never happened
never happened yeah and at this point
you have a you're really down on time
yeah so yeah and then you just move back
because now now f4 is vacant Oh a trick
I gotcha
okay good good good and then after this
I just made a move instantly without
thinking maybe here I don't know if 95
is better it might be Knight up here
there but they both look they both look
pretty pretty promising
so protects the pollen yeah Knight
attacks the Queen Knight back to his
home threads betrayed the night and you
say no way but now he is Knight takes d4
so I think I had to move my knight
somewhere else yeah that was when it was
looking kind of kind of shady for you
yeah and so obviously you can't take the
pawn because of Queen takes Queen so you
move the Queen out of the danger yeah
now he can instead of that he could have
just taken on e3
I don't see what's wrong with that Wow
he could have taken on e3 that's what
move I was recommending but I totally
was oblivious to this threat to the
Nightfort oh no Knight f3 doesn't work
as I do because yeah you take excellent
so yeah yeah this is when I was yelling
like you should just take it but he
doesn't I don't know he thought for some
time he's probably afraid of something
yeah because then it gets to passers but
uh Knight to f4 and then this is when he
can slam this one and I thought he was
doing excellent here yes and then then
we kind of just kind of drifted away
from this game because I thought like oh
my god that's gonna be lights out for
you but but you uh you get some counter
play here somehow so I'm very intrigued
on how how this ends up playing out so
you attack the Queen again Queen moves
yeah I go back ok just miss my threat
and ig6 if he didn't I mean after I win
the exchange he's still better but if he
didn't miss that then yeah this is just
terrible
yeah Knight takes rook takes and now
he's still better because he has two
pawns and like my p3 he's weak and stuff
but um his King is weak and we both have
like a minute or so right so yeah so now
you have to start playing you get you
have the attack now so he's got to be
he's kind of on the defending well and
when you're uh when you're down on time
right it's tougher to defend an attack
so so night he gets this attack and yeah
I did not like this plan of his I love
this night and way better on E no it's
not it's more that his back rank is weak
and he just doesn't realize like after
King g7 I can like oh yeah you get the
shot of it now now I can yeah instead of
Queen d6 if he goes King D 7 like even
Queen b8 is very so you everybody see
that if if the King goes to the light
square on d7 irons can jump into ba and
threatened Queen takes pawn Chuck and
all the girls for Queen d8 mate are
Queen to DA maybe I could get it gets a
couple spikes X yeah Queen to d8 that
mate that's a little bit better huh yeah
yeah this position after King c7 Queen
g3 probably this is already really good
for white if you played King g7 after
rook h8 wait go back yeah so like if you
played King d7 instead before King be
seven right here yeah then probably I
mean after rook
II can I get away with work eh one I'm
gonna lose my pond sooner or later
maybe then he's still probably doing
really well but yes to make sure he
doesn't get made it and that's not easy
with them okay so let's see how the game
really went and then this is your your
moment of Fame here
yeah after Queenie six I was this close
to playing Queen takes c6 I'm like oh
well trading Queens it's easier to play
them like oh yeah I totally missed it -
iris I was saying you have to trade
Queens and play rook e to instantly in
but luckily you know you've surveyed the
board looked at all your checks and came
up with the stomper work the CHS that's
why you need to do these taxes I mean if
this was given to you as a tactic you
would see it in one second but if you
you still have to do a lot of them so
that in cases like this don't miss it so
now like if King d7 trip thx oh yeah
right yeah I know but actually he should
have done that maybe rook well I think I
think King because that way you avoid
the check here yeah and then retreats
the back row so now you just have to
protect your rook he just played on
because like I played on right don't
wait till you're dead live and it turned
out this was a decisive match right it
turns out because we thought this was
already over the match but for the zag
diggy team at this point but but
fortunately for us I mean this was this
was the game clincher the match clincher
right yeah right so he shouldn't resign
here he's got a play on two to death I
guess and yeah you do very well mopping
it up
check and then yeah I loved this just
just get rid of his final threat here
and you do a great job on hunting down
that poem and and then amazing check and
then yeah he could play d3 here but then
obviously you just take it with the
Queen and that's all she wrote so
congratulations iris you clinched the
match for the st. Louis squad and I'm
sure they're all proud of you we're
about ready to have a pizza party here I
think and celebrate the big yeah match
victory here so lots of fun let's go to
a commercial break and maybe we can put
a bow on this when we come back
hi I'm Mike Matheny whether you played
chess for fun or want to boost your
child's academic performance come visit
the Chess Club and scholastic Center of
st. Louis right here in the chess
capital of the u.s. from a welcoming
diverse environment to a Scholastic
outreach program now in over 100 schools
our Center across from the world chess
all of Fame the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion for those of you who are
new to chess it might look like ba 3 is
an illegal move here because white
masters pawn to square is not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I'd
let say planking in seven Kingi - and
I'll try because y'all played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed at length during the course of
my steak yeah he told me this is
excellent
d5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think we might as well
know who Lawrence
this is not how chest works certainly
would be much much more fun if chest
actually work like this
I don't think it does well maybe it does
well that's me regretting what I just
said how did I get from there to here is
a little bit beyond me and what's worse
I will never hear the end of it my
quality of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
hello chess fans and welcome back to
today in chess where we talk about all
the happenings of the day in chess and
specifically today is a DD verse versus
st. Louis the match I'm Ben Simon along
with my comer and we're here to wrap up
the show with well we got to say the
reports of our demise were greatly
exaggerated and part of that is my fault
we have some corrections to issue so
let's take a look at the pairings right
now four boards 5 through 8 now we're
looking at the bottom boards first for a
reason because the top boards actually
culminated the match that was the climax
so here is the mix-up on board number 8
Adi Panda was slated to play black he
actually played white so we played the
match with five whites so look it's an
exhibition right it's all about having
fun so if they want to raise a fuss they
have a right I guess but no but
congratulations to Audie Potter because
white did win and it was a deed so there
is a one-point swing right there also in
the round
we had Shania did win against Newman and
then going up Selina lost to Nica we did
say that and then finally on board five
Aiden Wang did defeat shichi nama so
congratulations so that was a wash on
the bottom boards too - yes the match
will be determined by what happened on
one through four and we take a look at
one through four and there's a mix-up
here as well on boards one through four
we have to tell you first of all that we
were accurate in most cases it was just
three out of four history on board three
out of four ain't bad right so here are
the dot well we saw there we go one
through four so board for was a draw the
only one the the it was forced by Becca
via on
a board number three did have a Lika
defeating Aaron board number two let's
put a star next to this one because it
was incorrectly reported and it was my
fault I do apologize the way I had the
games displayed on my screen confused me
but it's some good news we have here
because it was not Sartana winning the
game it was Ashish Honda
so the pandas really came through for
the st. Louis club going to and oh yes
so she she got the checkmate with black
and so it actually all came down to
board number one iris and Bart shava so
iris wins match the final score is four
and a half to three and a half st. Louis
wins yeah so what looked like a
anti-climatic game for the iris was just
playing on playing on we thought no big
deal and it ended up that was the match
clincher so sorry - well it saved your
heart right cuz baby iris thought the
pressure was off and played and she got
the big comeback victory over satiny and
zoom dinghy if you were watching on lis
chest org you were thinking what the
heck are they talking about with those
two games but it's all good news for us
and we do think the Georgia team for a
great man for sure it was all a lot of
fun and I'm sure the Froyo gang and the
pandas are rejoicing right now yes so
maybe we'll meet again down the road
time will tell never know but you know
we're here with today in chess Mike and
it's been a big week in chess
oh sure actually in the u.s. because on
Tuesday the candidates ended man yep
there was a party in the central what's
that that's for sure champagne was
flowing and everybody was dancing in the
streets as the song says yep it was
great so Fabiano the st. Louis resident
Fabiano carry on o proud st. Louis
Archbishop as well
we'll be contesting Magnus Carlsen in
November
hopefully in st. Louis won't that be a
hoot and and yeah he's playing magnus
carlsen as we speak right I'm not too
sure as we speak but they they are
median in the first round in Greinke so
and that's kind of unusual sometimes you
have the world champion his challenger
playing you know during the time in the
cycle when it's determined they're gonna
meet so maybe we should check that out
they were playing in Berlin Germany this
was going all month long and ended on
Tuesday and we were in a position where
Fabiano Carolina in the position to be
the first American to challenge for the
lineal and true World Chess Championship
since 1972 at Bobby Fischer had to
perform well against Alexander Grisham
with the black pieces
it was a tough yet not impossible task
and as the round neared its conclusion
we saw that the what we once thought was
unthinkable may indeed happen in Fabiano
Kara Juana is slated to meet the world
chess champion in London later this year
right now we have a special video
package of the reaction here in st.
Louis as we got the news from Berlin all
right this last move is an indication
that
fabbi is and rook g1 and more he's not
offering the drama and I think back it's
dangerous especially because you see
that aren't you too
it's not so now it's a threat but it now
it's white and we have breaking news the
game is over
Fabiano marijuana has won against
Alexander in style Bravo come November
he will challenge Magnus Carlsen for the
world title and there are cheers going
on in the job this is a match everybody
has
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since you know how does it feel to watch
your youngster pull this off and is now
the Challenger to the world title
doesn't like a dream and maybe I wake up
but I'm very excited I'm very excited
for Fabiano either services I can't
believe it my life is
I'm absolutely thrilled I'm coming into
today I wasn't sure what would happen
and somehow things just came together
perfectly at the end so I really gonna
be happy I mean it's still so far away
but I'll prepare very seriously it'll be
a tough fight a tough fight indeed man
so much happening in that video package
you notice that little kid that was in
that group photo that is Jenna ha days
son named Fabian after who else poppy on
marijuana yeah Bobby I know yeah he just
wants to be called Bobby no other no
other nicknames needed just Bobby wish
it would have had my Fabi wins shirt on
today no it's a big deal you guys
and we were on kind of a five minute
delay from the official feed
so people were like should I glance
forward at the live moves or should I
wait and look at just 24 you know it was
a tough call because you were so excited
to see how Fabiano was gonna win this
tournament and become the Challenger for
the world champions right it was kind of
inevitable right and like two hours into
the match but grisha kept on and on and
on and wind and down grinding down and
eventually Bobby just winded them down
and Greece had enough the end and Bobby
advances to the kennedys unfortunately
not having a stellar day today but give
the guy a break okay saving it he says
save it save it which was probably my
recommendation anyway it looks like
Magnus has some passed pawns which was
kind of the theme of the day and it's
gonna get a queen and you know that's
alright this is in the Greinke
tournament is happening live right now
in Germany right yep playing against the
world champion Magnus Carlsen so Magnus
had all time to prepare for this match
and probably wanted to strike a little
fear into file B but Bobby has beaten
Magnus before as everybody remembers the
big 7 and o Sinquefield Cup start in
2014
yeah so he's got he beat him that day
and he drew him in the it was a double
round-robin so Bobby has some good
results
a magnus yeah a bit promising you know
maybe no one's winning against Magnus
right but they're promising and Magnus
I'm sure you recall in 2016
Magnus did not play in the Grand chest
tour because he was slated to defend his
title against Kerry Aachen later that
year correct
Fabiano Cara Juana is going for the
World Championship and he's not he's not
taking a breather you guys because he
not only is planing greggy but he's also
playing in the US Chess Championship
trying to regain the title that he won
in 2016
yeah and just cuz he's the UH he's
definitely the favorite but hey he's got
some tough competition in that event I
believe Grandmaster Wesley soul is going
to compete along with a geek or Nakamura
and you know when he Cora Nakamura is
playing anything can happen he's very
exciting a chess player and along with
uh you know our own Archbishop's through
grandmaster vara Cobian and grandmaster
uros Arabic we'll be back too so so hey
you can't take that lightly
and as Fabiano knows that's he actually
lost to as arab rook last year as well
but hey he's still Fabiano you know so
he is the favorites though it's a 12
player a round-robin
event we have the top three players that
we just mentioned and the rest of the
field but this US Championship is so
unpredictable we've seen Alejandro
Ramirez and Verico bian and others come
so close to the championship it's not a
given that those top three Nakamura so
and Cara wanna will be the winner and it
also at the same time as the 2018 US
Championship as always the 2018 US
Women's Championship the first round
kicks off on April 18th here in st.
Louis and if you can't be with us live
you can catch all the action at us chest
champs calm Mike this is the 10th year
we voted the u.s. championship
yeah we've been a very fortunate here in
st. Louis to have such a great facility
that the players want to to come here I
mean they love the facility and we love
to have it for him and I got to do one
quick shout out to a feat a master my
client
the chest life article and the artwork
is just spectacular in the preview of
the US Chess Championship in the US a
woman's championship
check out that that magazine it's
awesome art for just came out yeah yeah
it's hot off the shelves out off the
presses and it's a great article great
artwork in its it's really informative
and exciting the chest life holds number
one chess magazine for sure so that will
do it for us here in st. Louis we thank
you for joining us this show was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team
Isis Rises graphics and audio Danny
Machuca is your technical director we
want to thank the rest of the staff here
at the Chess Club for helping out today
and I'm here with the one and only
international arbiter Mike come on the
most entertaining man in chess
my name is Ben Simon and until the US
Championship on April 18th we say so
long from the Show Me State
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you